Connaissez-vous cette règle d'internet qui dit que si vous aimez quelque chose
un internaute a écrit une histoire de cul là dessus.
C'est une règle immuable d'internet.
Pour ceux qui ne savent pas ce qu'est une fanfiction, vous passez à côté de tout l'intérêt d'internet.
Les fanfictions sont des histoires écrites par des internautes.
Très souvent c'est de la romance, très souvent c'est autour de personnage de la pop culture, mais pas que. Et très souvent ce sont des romance homosexuelles
Si vous me demandez pourquoi je répondrais parce qu'internet. Voilà, on a lu une fanfiction avec avec SQUEEZIE n'est-ce pas tout le monde s'en souvient
là je suis sur le site "www.wattpad.com". C'est là où les gens postent des fanfictions. Il y de tous. C'est très
imaginatif. Il y a des fanfictions autour des personnages de mangas, autour d'Harry Potter et bien sûr, autour des Youtubers malheureusement je n'y fait pas exception.
Il y a quelques jours on m'a envoyé sur Twitter le lien vers une fanfiction. Malheureusement je suis dedans qui m'a fortement
interpellé. Je me suis dit "Quels ont été les connexions cérébrales de l'auteur". Êtes-vous prêts pour cette
histoire d'amour incroyable qui s'appelle YAOI. "Yaoi" c'est un genre de romance homosexuelle au Japon.
YAOI: Cyprien et François Hollande
Pourquoi? Ah ça fait longtemps ça. Alors vous êtes en droit de vous demander mais pourquoi François Hollande. En fait on a un petit peu un
élément de réponse. C'est que ben il y a très longtemps, il ya quelques années
j'ai eu un "échange" avec François sur Twitter: Oui François Hollande me follow
tranquillement au calme sur Twitter. Ça veut dire que je peux lui envoyer un message privé. "Whesh
poto ça fait quoi ce soir ?". Effectivement j'ai envoyé un message privé à François Hollande en 2015.
Malheureusement je suis obligé de vous le dire, plein de gens me posent la question, il ne m'a jamais répondu. Voilà.
Mais ça a suffit à ce que Nathan ait envie d'écrire une belle romance, une belle histoire d'amour comme si ces échanges allaient
continuer. Et puis c'est parti
"Chapitre 1: Un message inattendu"
« C'était un soir d'été, 21h30. Cyprien était assis devant son écran d'ordinateur
regardant ces messages privés Twitter  quand, soudain, un en particulier attira son attention
un message de François Hollande. Oui, un message de François Hollande. François Hollande le PRÉSIDENT (note de l'auteur: comme le fromage lol) »
OK on est en plus sur des auteurs de génie qui manient l'humour et le jeu de mots.
« Il ya quelques mois,
le Youtuber avait envoyé, pendant une vidéo, un message privé à François Hollande, car celui-ci l'avait suivi récemment sur son compte Twitter:
"Whesh poto ça fait quoi ce soir ?" Sauf que... il s'était pris un gros vent. Enfin un ouragan... »
C'est vra i. « Et après de loooooooooooooooooooooooooooooongs mois »
il ya beaucoup de "o" Je suis obligé de jouer un petit peu.
« Il avait enfin répondu. Il ouvrit la conversation, le coeur battant... Ils réfléchissait
à toutes les réponses possibles et imaginables que le président aurait pu lui répondre... »
F.H: « Yo mec, s'cuze, j'étais au conseil » C'est David Chabant, il a une chaîne Youtube, qui fait la voix de François Hollande
« Note de l'auteur: LA DROGUE C'EST PAS BIEN DIS LE A TES COPAINS »
Tout internet résumé en une fanfiction et une vidéo.
« Point de vue Cyprien: J'ai été
surpris, oui surpris c'est bien le mot. Je ne m'attendais pas du tout à ça. Surtout de la part du président
note de l'auteur: re le camembert) »
Une fois ça va... Deux fois ça va aussi . J'aime bien.
« Yo ça va » bah quoi je savais pas quoi répondre moi
« François répondit: OKLM
et toi posée mais euh
t'es pas occuper là bas pas trop non
là je suis en train de faire une partie de fléchettes sur une photo de marine le pen
ah ok sinon c'est pour quand la prochaine vid' bas je pense faire les objets what the fuck 2
pourquoi j'ai l'impression qu'il est un peu con mais je vais rester polis
c'est le président quoi bah j'sais pas elle va peut-être sortir pour les 9 millions
9 millions de quoi bah de saucisses évidemment what the cut note de l'auteur faites pas les cons on a tous compris
Ces gens là sont déterminés à faire le plus de jeux de mots et de référence au youtube français je vois c'est une obsession
tout est relou mec ouais j'avoue
Wesh frère ça te dis de remener ton boule à l'Élysée un d'ces 4?Qu'est-ce qu'il vous a prit les gars? trop d'internet mène à ça point de vue françois hollande bah
ben quoi je voulais parler comme le jeunes ah oui merde je suis vieux note de l'auteur
bah ouais frère
en le lisant je comprends le rythme de l'auteur j'aime bien mais je suis con quoi qu'est ce qui m'a pris de dire ça
bon maintenant c'est fait je vais pas m'en vouloir que
quoique je suis con putain voilà pour le premier chapitre bon là c'est rien mais c'est un début peace nathan et cacahuètes vide
super pseudo continuer la lecture de la partie suivante bien évidemment
chapitre de la connaissance
point de vue cyprien
je sais pas pourquoi mais je rougis et je me sens gêné je me rassis dans mon fauteuil et je n'ai pas envie de
répondre pour l'instant
tu dors poto? non non pas à cette heure là mais euh je parle maintenant comme le président mais c'est une influence création bah quoi
Et ben quoi? Ben c'est qu'on se connaît même pas enfin juste comme ça quoi si je t'ai envoyé un message c'est juste pour les abos
j'ai envoyé un message juste pour vous divertir ah ok je croyais que j'avais enfin un pote
ça clashe un peu j'aime bien non mais c'est juste qu'on se connaît à peine faudrait qu'on passe un peu plus connaissance
quoi bas j'sais pas je n'aurais jamais dit ça de ma vie bref hockey j'aime la piscine
et les chiens et toi? WHAT on arrive sur le président qui essaye
d'entretenir la discussion avec moi afin d'avoir un ami. Ce que j'aime bien c'est pour l'instant c'est pas sexuel donc c'est un exploit!
note de l'auteur j'ai beaucoup bu pour avoir cette idée tu m'étonnes ok il est un peu chelou
mais je vais faire un effort quand même je préfère les chats note de l'auteur je suis bourré NO KIDDING
bon alors après on a eu un débat le meilleur des deux entre le chien et chat j'imagine
c'est là que je découvre que j'ai vraiment rien d'autre à foutre de ma vie là donc l'auteur ne détaille même plus la conversation beaucoup
d'efforts pour des jeux de mots par contre dès qu'il faut un petit peu du propos cinglants là y'a plus personne
et surtout j'ai plein d'autres choses à faire de ma vie
moi je suis très occupé voilà je suis un youtuber je fais des choses c'est faux parfois j'ai un autre à foutre c'est les chats
les meilleurs points mais c'est de la merde
les chiens c'est mieux ils sont toujours avec toi bon bah sinon aux bonnes nuits hein je dois y aller bonne nuit
mais ça reste entre nous cette conversation ok d'accord ça c'est un chapitre je....
suis quelque peu déçu et je suis content que il n'y a pas réellement d'histoire d'amour ce qui fait que
c'est un peu moins cringe que prévu par contre, des auteurs sont partis
totalement en vrille si vous les connaissez n'hésitez pas à les aider psychologiquement les soutenir un petit chapitre trois: le rendez vous
Yessss!!Enfin une rencontre
je sais pas pourquoi je mangeaille sur une histoire improbable
excusez-moi point de vue françois hollande ça fait des mois que je lui cause, à ca type je me suis fait un ami et un
c'est beau c'est une relation d'amitié j'aime beaucoup note de l'auteur et bat putain je pensais pas que ça arriverait un jour champagne
champagne merci bref maintenant je suis en train de me taper les 11 heures le dauphin coquin note de l'auteur si vous connaissez ap c'est le grand JD
Notification twitter apparurent haut de mon écran c'est lui lui est en italique c'est important celui dont j'attends sa réponse depuis maintenant plus d'une semaine
en même temps vu ma dernière question je comprends dis moi
quand est-ce qu'on pourrait se voir mercredi 10h au starbucks euh ok genre je vais rencontrer
l'ancien président de la république dans un starbucks et là que vont dire les tabloïds des magazines people
il va me prendre sur son scooter il va se passer quoi ensuite
non mais vraiment pour le coup je trouve ça très mignon le fait de faire un personnage qui cherche un ami
qui n'est rien de sexuel ce qui est très rare sur wattpad je suis super excité
je vais enfin le rencontrer c'est génial c'est dans deux jours point de vue cyprien j'ai deux mots à lui dire
il se prend pour qui lui avec ces rapprochements à deux balles
il croit que je n'ai pas vu qu'il m'aimait ou quoi
je suis hétéro merde c'est un ami rien de plus je suis un personnage très sanguin dans cette histoire ok je suis je suis un Cyprien un peu
HÉ OH LÀ C'EST QUOI ÇA? IL VEUT ME RENCONTRER AU STARBUCKS  NON MAIS OH Clara qui est Clara Clara sera donc
incarné par jessica alba je suis le metteur en scène de cette histoire ok tu discutes avec qui un pote fait moi voir attend quoi
un pote un pote avec le titre de la discussion f h
c'est une autre fille c'est ça hein  avous mais non c'est parce que tu crois c'est peut-être
françoise félicia fanny flavie et se dit moi quand est-ce qu'on pourrait se voir c'est pas une fille ça
mais mais non je t'assure que non
normalement il aurait fallu que je dise ma réplique et qu'ensuite elle part sinon elle m'entend pas bref c'est ma copine depuis deux ans donc
voilà apparemment j'ai une copine depuis deux ans qui part parce que j'ai une relation amicale avec l'ancien président république internet
ça m'a vraiment énervé tout ça à cause de lui mercredi je vais lui dire ma façon de penser
j'éteins mon ordi en soupirant clara est parti et je ne sais pas combien de temps mais elle va revenir vite
j'espère en attendant je vais prendre une douche et voyant qu'il n'est toujours pas revenue je lui envoie un message et c'est bon fait pas
la tête je vais faire cuire des pâtes en prenant tout mon temps pour me faire croire que le temps ne passe pas
ok les gens font ça donc à ce moment là de l'histoire je me fais cuire des pâtes n'est ce pas
il est 21h hou précis en plus j'aime bien toujours pas revenu je lui envoie un autre message maintenant
morte inquiétudes ont maintenant tu reviens à la maison tout de suite je trouve ça un peu
directif j'attend un peut et après dix minutes je décide de manger mes pâtes devenues froides sur mon canapé oh putain
c'est tellement triste
je prends mon téléphone et compose un numéro une sonnerie plus deux trois enfin mon correspondant décroche allo oui allô lucas
Ohhh l'arrivé de Squeezie dans la place je me disais bien que une fanfiction avec moi il y a Lucas qui traine pas loin Chapitre 4
introduisons notre cypreezie petite parenthèse merci pour les
1000 Je pense que c'est les 1000 vues c'est la fête balancez patrick sébastien par la fenêtre
sans déconner, c'est un truc de ouf ouf merci merci bande de patates des mers vous vous rendez pas compte mais c'est un truc de malade pour nous piti écrivains de la campagne
perdue putain eh bien vous savez quoi
ce petit message de ces auteurs
probablement jeunes qui avant des histoires débiles mais avec plein de blagues et des petits retournement de situation et ils sont très contents des lectures
et des retours et ben moi je trouve ça beau voilà ça c'est l'internet beau arrivé devant la porte de lucas je toc
à ma vu il ouvre grand les yeux il était en pyjama saucisses et salue sip paraissait gêné surpris de voir
ça va j'ai téléphoné il ya une demi-heure pour te prévenir que je souhaitais ton appart il rosie aux ide vers rose
oui oui tout va bien je suis au courant il va rester planté là à me regarder mal à l'aise bon bah
tu blesses crever dehors ou comment
ils reculent note de l'auteur j'ai trop imaginer le mec qui fait une haie marche arrière avec son camion
je suis pressé à l'intérieur de son appartement
Arrivé dans le salon spacieux je déposais mons est accusé sur le tapis motifs saucisses avant de me laisser tomber sur un fauteuil au motif
papillon une certaine obstination pour les saucisses que je ne peux expliquer c'est le fauteuil de louise on dira que louise est incarnée par
emilie ratage ops qui m
au fait j'espère que ça ne la dérange pas non non t'inquiète pas je me sentais comme bizarre je vais chercher des bières on pourra
parler au clair après ok ça c'est la réplique
ok j'attendais patiemment qu'il revienne quand j'ai entendu des bruits de pas dans le couloir quand une silhouette en peignoir apparu
salut louise salut sip enlève tes chaussures s'il te plaît j'ai passé la spi ce matin waouh il ya de l'action
les répliques fusent des punchlines incroyable elle continue d'avancer puis se stoppe en est et se retourna vers moi sip
qu'est ce que tu fais ici
je lever un sourcil bas je dors ici est nourrie grand les yeux et se tourner vers la cuisine lui
lucas revient
ventre à terre et fit une grimace quand il aperçut louise lui je peux savoir ce que six pays 6 à 3 heures 12 du
matin bref je me sens et draguer pas
à tourner
Et malheureusement comme tu peux le remarquer tués dans cette fan fiction également avant il ya ma copine qui m'a largué parce que j'ai changé
des messages avec le président françois hollande du coup l'auteur a décidé que j'allais
dormir chez toi finalement je te réconforter sa et caisses qui achètent ouailles à ta copine qui s'appelle louise qui est incarnée par emilie ratage
aux chips je suis réalisateur elle me découvre sur ton canapé et en est là et je pense que je vais arrêter ce chapitre
monaco il ya là je suis pas 4 ou 5 à dallas
Je me faisait draguer par françois hollande venait sûrement de me faire larguer par ma copine à cause de ça avait mangé des pas trop
froide et maintenant j'assistais à une dispute entre mon meilleur ami mon meilleur pote et sa meuf dans son salon beaucoup trop cher pour moi
entièrement
évolutif saucisses à nice
Finalement à l'issue de cette rude bataille j'ai eu le droit de rester dormir sur le tapis le tapis sur six
épisodes attentes sur ce chapitre
désolé on espère que ça vous a plu chez pas commettre à la faim et à la prochaine pour les autres chapitres qui risque d'être
un peu plus aventureux chao nathan et cacahuètes vivre ainsi les prochains
Au maintien au plus haut point de vue duquel je prends fin aux guerres
il est 5h30 et comme tous les jours
louise se lève sans faire de bruit pour ne pas grever
mettant rishq tu meurs comme tous les autres riches que tu verras ce moment j'ai la nintendo switch et j'ai joué toute la nuit j'ai
attendu le temps qu'elle se préparer quand il n'y avait plus de bruit je décide de me lever à mon tour il est 6 heures
02 et je sort péniblement de mon lit que je passe devant le salon je trouve cyprien allongé sur le tapis que je lui ai
donné hier je m'arrête pour le regarder dormir paisiblement qu'est-ce qu'il est mignon quand il dit
Merde mais à quoi je pense moi je suis vraiment pas réveillé je réfléchisse heures minutes enfin quatre minutes et 18 secondes exactement je passe
à pas de loup à côté de lui
La vache et leur oncle fort le secoue un peu pour le réveiller mais il ne bouge pas et ronfler juste plus fort
or c'est pas possible ça tu peux vous prendrez croft eu le secoue
vraiment il peut mariages les plus forts se faire sans escale j'essaie de le soulever mais j'ai encore deux lâchera putain chambre
merde je réussis avec peine à le traîner jusqu'à ma chambre
ici sur mon lit attendant je make it a filé un tapis pour dormir dessus et le matin il fait genre il est mignon quand
même à jeter mais dans mon lit ça n'a aucun sens je le remet correctement et me couche à kout
Je me la couette papillon sur nous et me rapproche doucement de lui et me blottis dans ses mémoires
ok maintenant le réveil de ce prix on sait tout de suite je me réveille durement dans un endroit qui me paraît plus confortable que
ce foutu tapis que lucas bad des mamours donné hier je vous les yeux et la première chose que je chut un réveil qui indiquait
11h53 je suis pour que tendent à lentement heavy lucas l'outil contre mon épaule
putain il est mignon quand il dort on aurait dû s'arrêter avant mais j'étais pas là c'était une histoire d'amitié avant la garde avec françois
hollande pourquoi je pense ça bordel je vais vraiment pas bien mais je tente de me lever sans le faire bouger mais je crois qu'il
est vachement bien accroche bon tant pis je réveille doucement
moins dormir lui du car il se réveille en sursaut trempé de sueur qua non mais c'est pas mal enfin
lui qui se retourne vers moi kramo à 6 g moisi
tout peut apporter terre aussi aux grosses chaleurs la moitié mais je suis clair un morceau de viande à
salut ça va bien dormi je veux c'est un sourcil
aux très bons soient ils étaient musique soit était vraiment très con
et le connaissant je pense qu'il peut très bien être les deux en même temps s'ils sont rouges cio mais c'est pas faux où alors
il sait très bien ce que je foutais ici il me regardait toujours visiblement extrêmement gêné je me racle la gorge
lucas tu peux me dire ce que je dis
hing oui al oqla à mon dieu ça va ou est ce que tu es passé putain tu m'as fait une peur bleue
non je suis pas la maison je suis chez
je me tourne vers lucas qui regarde fixement devant lui toujours bouchut look tarn un choix stabilo coiffe un moment
j'examine la chambre des papillons et des soucis spartoo away n'ont rien laissé tomber weeds dans 20 minutes oui j'arrive à léa plus je raccroche
lucas
oui
je dois y aller ok
c'est les auteurs qui ont
écrit ces répliques incroyable je me lève sort de la pièce je vais chercher mon sac côté du tapis ceci ce jeu fait georges et
oublier ce qui vient de se passer dans les quatre prochaines minutes pour le bien de tous sera mieux je m'habille et sort
attendait pas du tout c'est horrible non moi j'ai moi même
ça m'a plu j'ai battu ces jeux-là temps et cacahuètes vide on attend la suite puis celle ci elle a une saveur particulière
la bravo à nathan bravo
Merci les internautes pour tant de créativité de plaisir merci lucas d'avoir incarné ton propre rôle
Je vous dis à très vite sur internet mais pas de vous abonner
Oh
#FrancoisHollandeetcyprienclip